okay thanks ryan and thank you for the
invitation um
i'm not that great at all this
technology so if you ask
questions i can see there's two
different things for questions and i
don't know if i'll see them but
um maybe the chair can tell me if
there's one there or something like that
um the other thing is because of the
time zone
and other things i'll be watching a lot
of these talks
out of sync and um so
if you have any questions that you
wanted to ask me feel free to just send
an
email and hopefully that'll all work out
somewhat um
unconnected okay so i'm going to be
talking about counting solutions to
random cnf
and this is joint work with andreas
golanis heng guo
and kuan yang okay so we'll start with
the ksat model which
i'm sure you're familiar with um we're
going to let k
be the number of literals in each clause
so here k is three
we're going to have n billion variables
um so i guess they go up to six here
and m clauses here there's four and
the model we're going to work in is
going to fix k
so the number of literals per clause but
we're going to work in the random case
at
model which means that if you're given n
the number of variables
and m the number of clauses you just
choose
the formula uniformly at random so every
literal there's two n choices you just
take one
okay so the way the model is going to
work is actually that we're going to
also fix
the density of the formula which is the
number of clauses
divided by the number of variables
and if you fix both k and the density
then you know the input is n
and then there's a random formula and
we're interested in how um
how the probability of satisfiability
changes as the density
increases okay so there's been lots of
work on this question
um so much that i had to make a pretty
small font um
loads of it by people here who know more
about this than i do
um but a neat thing that's true is that
there's a um
there's a phase transition at some
critical density alpha star
depending on k so that if your density
is below this
then with high probability of
probability one the formula is
satisfiable
in the limit as n goes to infinity and
above it it goes to zero
so not very dense likely to be
satisfiable drops to zero
and um a few years back ding sly and
soon
managed to actually um pin down this uh
this alpha star and so put the value
here for you it's about 2 to the k
times log 2 and some other stuff okay
so so that's uh so that's a super
um good and um
what we're going to do then is look at
some algorithmic questions
connected to this um to this phase
transition
okay oh and i noted here that their
proof was by the second moment method
and i slipped in some notation that
we're going to use so for us
if i is always going to be the number of
satisfying assignments
and sometimes i'll call them solutions
means the same
thing okay so that's the model so we've
got
a random formula we fix the density we
know that if it's below alphasar
it's likely to be satisfiable above it's
likely not to be
all right so the first question you
might ask is let's suppose that the
density is below
alpha star so with probability one the
formula is satisfiable
can you actually find a satisfying
assignment
and um the best polynomial time
algorithm
that we have for this is due to amin
koya oglin
and it succeeds with high probability
over the choice of the formula
when alpha maybe that's hard to see um
when health is uh
a little bit less than the
satisfiability threshold so remember
that satisfyability threshold was about
2 to the k times the log of two
and ambien's work here is saying that as
long
as alpha is um emotes that divided by k
then you can actually find a satisfying
assignment
and what we actually know is that this
factor of k is kind of important because
um together with the midterms amin
showed um
give some evidence that the problem's
likely to be hard if alpha's um
if alpha's bigger than um about 2 to the
k over k
because that's where the solution space
has a phase transition and the
satisfying assignments are not
connected so for example if you had a
local algorithm you definitely wouldn't
be able to get from
between the solutions okay
um but we're interested also in the
number of satisfying assignments
and so the second question you might ask
is um not just finding one but can you
approximate
this number of satisfying assignments
and of course as
you on those sometimes we don't really
want to approximate z itself
but we might want to approximate its log
to get it various some
physical quantities now what we know
about this
um going back to abe monteneri
is that actually this is concentrated
around its expectation
so the log of z that is the log of the
number of satisfying assignments
is concentrated around this expectation
um
when alpha's below this 2k over k the
place where the phase um
solution space is all connected uh but
unfortunately we don't really have a
formula for the expectation
um in for this model and that's because
true and false are sort of asymmetric so
although there are some models where we
do have such formulas this isn't one of
them
uh however we do have a um
an approximation algorithm so um in
uh 2007 once an arian shah gave a
polynomial time approximation scheme for
the log
when alpha is less than some quantity
here which i'll talk about in a second
okay so i want to pick out a few things
about this
um polynomial time approximation scheme
just means for any epsilon you can get
the log of the number of solutions quite
close within a factor of one plus or
minus absol
cylon um what is this bound on
alpha you might be surprised at first
because it's little of one
as a function of k whereas i've been
talking about two to the k
um but it actually does have a meaning
um and it's actually the gibbs
uniqueness threshold if you put the
model on an infinite tree
okay and their method was um which we'll
talk more about in a minute is
estimating the marginals
so for every um variable working out
a close approximation to the probability
that it's true
in the uniform distribution on
satisfying assignments
they use correlation decay or belief
propagation
to estimate these marginals
all right so for us we have um in this
work two questions that we wanted to
answer
um and one is that we wanted um we
wanted a better approximation to
z and that's because um if you
approximate the log
within one plus or minus cylon of course
you're still
exponentially off on z so we were hoping
to get a good approximation to the
number of satisfying assignments itself
and that's that's what we um do
um but the second and kind of primary
focus is that we are interested in
having a higher alpha
and in particular in getting one that's
um that's exponential so remember that
the satisfiability threshold
is about 2 to the k log 2. we are
interested in getting as close to that
as we could and in particular in getting
something exponential in k
um we achieved something exponential in
k but probably not the constants that
you'll like
so let me uh let me tell you about that
uh
so what we get we do get an f p test for
z
um for densities which are
almost 2 to the rk for some constant r
actually maybe it's easier to just do it
formally so um
what the theorem says is that you can
fix constants k
naught and r so that as long as the
number of um
literals per clause k is um
big compared to k naught and as long as
alpha is at most two to the r
okay so it's an exponential function but
it depends on this
r then there's a polynomial algorithm
with high probability of the choice the
formula
which when it's given the formula
outputs a good approximation i can see
there's a
question yeah leslie if you can't see it
i'll read it it's from priscilla
of andre it says if the value of logs
that is concentrated on a random
instance wouldn't one output the
expected value to be a ptas
okay right but um so what one situation
is that it's concentrated but we don't
have a good formula for the expected
value
even yeah right i also had a question
the algorithm is
also randomized given uh phi or it's
deterministic given phi
ah okay um i guess it doesn't matter in
this case
it's going to be deterministic given
five but i guess i'd be happy with one
that's randomized
given phi as well yeah it seems fine i'm
just curious decent question yeah
um okay cool and
um this value of r if you
try to figure out in our paper what it
is it's about one of your 300.
um now although that's not optimized i
definitely doubt that we could improve
it too much so it's a pretty
we're shooting for exponential um but
there's a lot of work to be done to get
um close to the decay and i'll
come back to that at the end okay
um our bridge um because the um
state space is uh disconnected in this
regime or the the
set of satisfying assignments we we
can't really um rely too easily on local
algorithms
and our proof relies on an approach of
moitra um
really nice work of mojo which gives a
fully polynomial approximation scheme
for bounded degree formulas and what i
mean by bounded degree
is that um he worked on the case where
every variable can be invo
init most a constant number of clauses
and i'll talk a lot
um about well a lot in 15 minutes
about um you know what
what the reason for this bounded degree
and and really for us the main
difficulty is dealing with the fact that
of course in a random formula you do
have
high degree variables okay so what i
want to do now
is i want to give you some notation and
come back to estimating by the marginals
because that's what i
um that's what moisture did and what um
we're gonna do
all right i'm just gonna use omega phi
to be the set of all uh
satisfying assignments um if i don't say
i'm always talking about
in the uniform distribution over that
and this will be familiar to a lot of
you a method for
approximating zed via the marginals is
just to fix
some satisfying assignment
and doing that suppose that um you take
the variables in order
and suppose that for each variable j
you can estimate what's the probability
that um the um that variable
j takes the value aj conditioned on the
previous ones
if you multiply those together you
obviously get the probability
of this assignment which is in the
uniform distribution one over z
so lovely if you can approximate these
things um
then you should take the estimate to be
1 over that
okay and often this approach is used
with correlation to k to estimate these
um
these marginals we can't do that here
because there's a whole lot of
correlation
i'm so following moisture we'll be doing
something else
so what moiter does in the boundary
degree case
is that he um he did what he called
marking some of the variables in each
clause
and the key fact about the marking is
that every clause has
a bunch of marked variables and also a
bunch of unmarked variables
if you do that he did he insisted on one
more thing which is that the formula can
be satisfied
using the marked variables
okay um so
then what you can do is suppose you
estimate the marginals of the marked
variables
then if you estimate those
um once you've have this assignment on
oh dear
once you have this assignment on the
marked variables
you've already satisfied all the clauses
so every other variable can be
whatever it likes so multiply by two to
the number of unmarked variables and you
still get one over the number of
assignments um
okay so that's the goal so the goals to
um for him
is to estimate the marginals of the
marked variables
now the key fact that made the idea work
is that the clauses
never become short because you'd always
have these unmarked variables hanging
around
and that's lovely because all the
marginals are near half and that's
really useful
uh how did he estimate the marginals
well he did that by satisfying a certain
linear program
and um nothing don't explain it in
detail in a short talk
but um it's better to get the ideas the
size of the linear program turns out to
be polynomial bounded
whenever a certain process couples
quickly
so we'll talk about that and if it
couples quickly
then the linear programming is bounded
the linear program
you solve the linear program and you're
able to then
estimate these marginals which gives you
what you need
okay so i'll talk i'll talk more about
that but that's the basic idea
okay bad news for the random k-stat
formula
is that um unfortunately for us of
course it's not bound to degrees so if
you take any constant c then there's
going to be a linear number of variables
that have degree bigger than c
and the maximum degree is clearly about
log n
um and that's terrible because these
high degree variables they don't have
marginals near half they have marginals
that can be arbitrarily close to zero
one and worse than that there's kind of
a domino effect because
even low degree variables can have bad
marginals if they share
um clauses with a high degree variable
so um so the basic
technique is really nice but we're not
going to be able to um well we have to
figure out how to deal with these
high degree variables
all right but before i tell you more
about that what i want to do is tell you
um a little more about moitra's method
because i think um
especially in a short talk it's probably
even best that you just take that away
because it's quite
cute um so i told you that he estimates
the marginals using
a linear program and the linear program
is set up to kind of
model a certain coupling process
so i'm going to tell you what the
coupling process is and then i'll give
you a little idea what this linear
program actually is
okay so let's say we have some variable
v star which is just some variable
whose marginal we want to estimate in
the uniform
distribution which i called mu
all right um so what am i going to do i
want to estimate the marginal
and i could consider the probability
that this variable
could be true or it could be false and i
could look at the set of
solutions conditioned on those two
things and
the coupling process that's relevant
couples
the uniform distribution conditioned on
v being true v
star being true with the uniform
distribution conditioned on v
star being false so what the coupling
looks like is you start out and you have
two assignments
one of which make the v star true the
others that make the v star false
and at the outset they disagree on one
variable which is v
star okay you'd like to kind of
couple these two distributions so to do
that what you do is you take a clause
that's not satisfied
in at least one of the copies and you
try to assign
the um values to the marked variables in
that clause
according to the marginal distributions
coupling them as
well as you can so there's a kind of a
tree describing the coupling that we
take
um two distributions and we consider
making v
true in both or true and then false or
false and then true or false and
then false and the idea is that um this
is a thought process we're doing this to
create the linear program
and we want to couple them so that
they're very you know that most of the
weight
comes for agreement okay
and if you um if you if a variable
causes a disagreement it has to get
added to the disagreement set
and then you have to keep going so
that's the coupling process in very
rough terms
what's the linear program well if you
imagine
sorry leslie can ask a quick question
yeah is the relationship between the
like the marked variables and the
unmarked variables and the disagreement
set
um yeah sorry it's it's kind of hasty um
so this is only learning the marginals
of the marked variables
and in moitra's world the marking
the marked variable satisfy and what
he's going to do is just find the
marginals of the marked variables and
then that's good enough because he can
multiply by two to the number
of unmarked for us it's cause a bigger
problem as we'll see but
um so these are all marked does that
answer your question okay
thanks cool okay and uh so what's gonna
happen is
for this coupling tree which you're just
thinking about
um what the linear program is going to
do is it's going to um
it's going to have two linear
programming variables for each node of
the coupling tree
and we're not going to in this talk put
down what exactly are the constraints of
this
linear program but what you should think
about is that what the constraints do is
they essentially make the coupling
behave properly
and there's constraints that say
disagreement's pretty unlikely okay so
that's
that's the point of this linear program
and what happens is uh two things there
are two key lemmas in moitras which are
still going to be true for us
which um well yeah um which are that
remember we're trying to learn the
number of satisfying assignments in
which v
is true divided by the number of
satisfying assignments which
in which it's false and if you can set
the two constants in the linear program
so that this ratio is between them maybe
our law is super small and our upper
super big
then there will be a satisfying
assignment of the lp that satisfies all
the constraints
and the second fact is that if you get
any solution to the lp
between those two bounds lower and upper
it actually gives you a kind of tight
bound
on omega 1 and omega 2. so seeing this
you can now guess the basic algorithmic
idea which is that you
somehow or other find in our lower and
our upper
that are really far apart and straddle
the truth
and then you start just making them
closer and closer by binary
search and as you do that you're
approximating the marginal that you want
okay now in my just bound to degree case
the marginals are all
really close to a half that's what the
marking does
so coupling is super likely um so that's
really good
um oh i should i skipped all this stuff
here sorry i was watching the clock
um if the um what do we find we find
that if we need the linear program to
have polynomial size otherwise we can't
run it so we can't have too many nodes
and in this coupling tree but
if we look at the variables that are set
in the two assignments
what is it well it's the ones that
disagree together with the variables
that share clauses with them
and so what we're going to need is for
that to be log n so that's going to be a
really important thing that's going to
have to be true
in moitus case marginals are all a half
so the coupling
goes quickly and that turns out to be
true
now in the case of random ksat we get
bad variables by which i mean variables
that have bad marginals that are not
near a half
and remember there's a domino effect
that they're the high degree ones and
anything that shares closes with high
degree ones and so on
so what we do um
our intuition is that these high degree
variables are not too clustered
and that's because the average degree of
the formula is bounded
so um what we do is we use an idea that
was inspired by
amin and panagiotu which is that we um
we run a little kind of bootstrap
percolation process to try to figure out
which variables are causing the trouble
so
to start out with the high degree
variables they're bad so we know that
any clauses that have a lot of variables
they're bad
but the variables that are in bad
clauses they're bad and we just keep
doing this
until there's no more badness in the
world and when we get done
by construction what we have is a set of
good clauses that don't have many bad
variables
and bad clauses only have bad variables
and the important point of all this is
two things the marginals of the good
variables turn out to be near half
well that's kind of a construction
because good good clauses don't have
many bad
variables and and also there aren't that
many bad variables well there's a linear
number but it's a small linear number so
we're going to be able to deal with it
okay so what is our goal
so what our goal and our method is going
to be what we're going to do is we only
mark
the good variables and um
we can still use um the lovish local
lemma again to show that there is
um we can mark the good variables in
such a way that we can um
that the good variables satisfy all the
good clauses
we have to ensure that there exists an
assignment of bad variables that
satisfies the bad clauses because
there's nothing else to satisfy those
we're going to learn the marginals of
the good variables
using a method sort of like moitras
but in order to do that
end game where you um where we used to
multiply by two times the number of um
bad variables here we have to actually
be able to compute the number of
satisfying assignments of bad clauses
and what we do is we do this by
enumerating all assignments to bad
variables so
if that sounded a little exotic the key
fact is that when you look at the kind
of
factor graph formed by the random
instance the bad components have to have
size
log in and that turns out to be a really
key thing and actually almost all the
technical work
is establishing this fact
okay so let me um just say i can see
everyone's got a minute and a half so i
want to just um
just say a little bit more about that so
what do i mean by this factor graph
well if you look at the formula and you
look at the variables and the clauses
and this edge here oh i can't color an
edge okay i don't you probably can't see
my pointer it doesn't matter there's an
edge from a variable to a clause
if the variable's in that clause i've
colored
the bad ones blue and and what i just
want is that if you look at a component
in this factor graph and you look at its
variables what we need to prove is that
with high probability these are only
logan
and actually to make this method work
it's even worse because um
during the coupling if you ever
encounter a bad variable
you have to add all variables from the
bad component into the disagreement set
um so we certainly need the bad
components of size
at log n but you actually also need any
variables that
share clauses with them also to have
size log n
but that turns out to be true so that
works
okay um great so i think what i want to
do since i've just got
21 seconds is i want to so the main
technical part
is proving that when you look at the
random formula
that um the connected components caused
by these bad variables just have size at
most log n
supposing you do that what you end up
with then
is an fp test when the density is at
most two to the r
ah is that my timer yes whoops uh sorry
okay um so you end up with an fp test
when the density is at most two to be rk
and um questions might be
could you improve the bound on alpha
because we got exponential in k
but remember the satisfiability
threshold is actually 2 to the k log 2.
um could you get closer to that and
also a faster algorithm because actually
this linear program it's called its
polynomial size but it's not exactly
small
okay and i think i'm going to stop there
thanks
all right thanks very much leslie uh i
don't yeah i don't know how we applaud
uh it's a constant dilemma
in zoom actually i saw a suggestion yeah
that you should just applaud in american
sign language which is very easy i think
it's like this
but i don't know we'll see if we can do
it um
yeah so uh great uh this is a wonderful
time for questions i think for questions
probably people can just unmute
themselves
and pipe up
no i don't think attendees can unmute
themselves you're currently talking
about is that because you're a panelist
yeah oh i see
hmm well if you have a question i
suppose you should
type it it's a little strange um
can i ask a question while popping up
yeah by the way we can also do the
raised hand thing and then
the panelists can i assume the hosts can
unmute whoever has raised their hand
but do we see attendees
the raised hand thing is under the
participants
and by the way i'm counting on you to
tell me because i have my slide shared
so i can't see all that but one of you
can tell me
yeah we'll tell you a little yeah okay
uh go ahead david yeah uh leslie thank
you for a very nice talk
i'm curious if the polynomial
interpolation method
um by barabina complex polynomial
interpolation method can give anything
in this regime have you thought about
that
we have we okay we haven't thought about
that on this problem but actually on a
rather
similar in a similar context and
actually the um
i i don't know how to do it because
again of the high degree um
variables which um
yeah um again i don't right i okay i
should just have said i have thought
about it but i don't know how to do it
yeah uh leslie i have more questions for
you that i can read out i'm just trying
to like organize it here but
um apparently you can i can unmute you
if you raise your hand but it's also
fine to use this q and a feature so i
have a question from uh nike sun
she said i think you could miss uh sorry
i think you said it but i missed it
could you briefly explain again why two
to the rk
is the bound oh okay uh good question i
i don't really think i did say it um
uh well what do i say about that um
that's the point at which we could prove
that um the bad closes of size at most
log n
and furthermore that in this coupling
process that if you
kind of locally what do you pick up that
that's at most log in
um it may be true uh better than 2 to
the rk but that was where we
stopped being i mean maybe nike knows
can prove something better but that was
that was
um the bound at which we could prove
those two things
uh great i should mention also that like
we built in this 15 minutes so there
could be like lots of questions so if
you just like want to leave and take a
break go ahead but otherwise we may just
keep quizzing leslie if it's okay with
her for like you know the full 15
minutes
so i have another question uh well two
more questions well that's the first one
from uh
prasad teddily which is also a related
question i was going to ask prasad asks
what's known for k-n-a-e sat and i was
also going to ask like i mean to what
extent do the arguments depend on the
fact that you're talking about ksat as
opposed to
um some general constraint satisfaction
problem but maybe you can start prasad's
question about nae said
okay so um and there will probably be
people on the participant list who know
more
about k naughty set than i do and they
should come in and say more
but um as far as i understand um
because that's symmetric it's easier to
get at
okay i'm not saying this is a perfect
answer but it's easier to get at the
expectation
because of the fact that the um that the
true and false are actually symmetric
and so i imagined that uh
let me just go back
um if you were looking at methods
like uh where'd my slides go
um so concentration around the
expectation
and then trying to compute the
expectation this should be easier for
not all equals that but um
but those of you that are experts and i
i i don't know what the right
what the bounds are and what's known
okay who does though on this call i
don't know
probably we have like over 80 people
which is awesome uh
feel free to pipe up if you know the
answer in the meanwhile i'll continue to
ask
questions of you leslie so we have a
question from andres corada
he asks uh has someone considered using
the disagreements between three
not two sets could that give more
information
okay that's a um it's an interesting
idea i
don't know how to do it offhand because
where the two sets come from
is um in the coupling tree what you do
and i think it
you start with some variable who's
marginal you want to learn
and you um you consider making it true
and making it false
so these are the the two assignments
that you're um
that you're considering and as you um
as you make decisions as you go down the
tree it's always there for those two
things that you're comparing so i don't
know
i i don't really know how you would reel
in a third one but that doesn't mean it
doesn't make sense it just means i don't
know how to do it
could i ask a question yeah
so um i i wasn't familiar before with
moisture's work so i'm very happy to
learn about it and about yours thank you
the if every satisfying assignment had a
witness
consisting only of the marked variables
in other words a partial assignment of
those
that explained why uh all the clauses
can be satisfied
then by enumerating all assignments of
the marked variables you would get an
exact counting algorithm right
so um is it
is it obvious that there's no
interesting density at which
that happens if for instance you choose
the marked variables randomly maybe with
giving some priority to high degree
variables
okay so let me first take it in moitra's
context where there are no high degree
variables and then come
back to that yeah so in his case um
the number of marked variables is is
linear right
okay okay but we don't learn them
exactly the marginals of the marked
variables we only learn them
approximately
and the reason for this is that i i kind
of suppress the fact
that in this coupling tree what you have
to do
is you have to truncate it at some point
i mean i said that
that you'll keep it polynomial size as
long as the coupling dies out
but what's really going on is that the
coupling dying out is allowing you to
truncate
but when you truncate you do lose
something so you're not getting those
marginals
perfectly so you get the marked ones
marginals you multiply them together and
then you know that the unmarked ones in
moisture's case they just two to the
whatever
now in our case um
you still account for the rest
accurately because what we get is that
the components
of the bad variables are actually small
size log n and we do it by brute force
so you still get that aspect perfectly
but yeah you were learning the marked
variables
roughly does that answer your question
or
no uh i think it does
i mean i i if if we had a set of
variables where
where we knew that every satisfying
assignment
could be accounted for with a partial
assignment of those variables
and that all other variables were free
then it would just be a
a union of these sub-cubes and we could
count everything exactly but i guess we
don't know that and
um so
yeah and also they're big so in mojo's
method we in moitra's case we do know
that the satisfying assignment can be
satisfied by the marked
variables they're chosen to ensure this
but yet
we don't know um exactly what the
marginals of the mark variables are
because there's a lot of them there's a
linear number of them so we can't just
um
break force it or something i think it's
very likely that counting
exactly even random instances is hard
just like counting random permanent this
part
even at very low densities i mean
super low below giant component of
course not
but above that
it's like
oh yeah oh sorry no no no this is not
the direct refutation of the method
chris you're proposing
of course but just generic thought
go ahead yeah i just had another
question so so it seems like this method
is also relying on the fact that
many variables have marginal really
close to a half
um but but it really high densities
close to the
threshold we don't expect that to be the
case anymore correct so
um like is there really hope that this
method can go
all the way probably not and um
actually definitely not um so actually
what i wanted to say
except for that i made too much um so
what yeah what i wanted to say is that
if you were
gonna try to get closer to the threshold
and not all the way there
um you might start with the monotone
case
okay uh because at least you've got a
connected state space there
um and there i wanted to mention some
work of hermann slyon's i'm sorry it
will become relevant
it sounds like it went off on a weird
tangent but um there was a point here
and there there was a really nice word
by herman sly and zhang that show that
um
how to do this um in the bounded degree
case
where d is at most c to the 2 to the k
over 2 and that's what i was trying to
get to
and we do actually know that that's
optimal up to the constant
c so we're not going to do better than
um 2 to the k
over 2. um but maybe what i'm saying is
you know why should it be 2 to the k
over
300 so i'm not suggesting you'll get all
the way to the threshold but
but i don't think that ours is as good
as you could do okay
thank you yeah i have a question too can
i pause you just for one second sit down
i'm afraid uh go find nike got in before
you so hold that thought uh now i have a
question from nike sign a bit of a
technical question also related to the
marginals she asks
um if you considered a modified version
of random ksat where all variables are
constrained to have bounded degree
i would have thought that marginals
could still be far from half due to the
true false asymmetry
is that issue already taken care of by
moitra's algorithm
yes so the way that moitra deals with
this
uh is to do with the marking so
if you go back um
where'd that go so
sorry about this yeah so if you go back
to the moisture marking um
so what moisture starts with is there's
two properties i want to talk about in
the in the marking
one each clause has to have a lot of
marked variables but
more important has well more important
for what i want to say right the second
it also has a lot of unmarked variables
as well
and um what we're going to do is leave
those
entirely unconditioned we're never going
to look at them and so there's kind of a
lot of room
there so because of this marking that
there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of space around the
marginals are on their half
and um well okay so you can use the
lover's local lemma to find
such a marking and then um
yeah and then the marginal's in your
half so he had that issue too
and that worked out um in our case the
trouble is that the high degree
variables and ones that share clause
with them
they're just not near a half and yeah
so so we can't learn those and we um
we can't satisfy all the clauses
using the ones that we can learn so we
have to figure out what to do about that
and the way to do that is learn the
marginals of the so-called good ones
and prove that the bad ones are all
broken into these small components that
can kind of just be dealt with
thanks let's take one more question from
siddhanth siddhant you have your
question
uh yeah so actually um do these
techniques also extend to
counting say approximately satisfying
solutions
like let's say you want to count number
of solutions to satisfy more than
99 of classes
huh um it's a good question i haven't
thought about it at all so probably what
i say will turn out to be nonsense but
um
yeah that's interesting uh
well it sounds more complicated but i
don't i don't see any reason why um
inherently why it wouldn't be a good
thing to try
yeah it hasn't been done
but a similar question would be the
non-zero temperature
partition function
uh true yeah maybe something that we can
uh we can all work out
during the workshop and uh have some
follow-on work
sorry can you answer questions uh who
was asking it was it jane
yeah go ahead it might be a little late
for jumping but we'll continue go ahead
all right so so um this moisturise
um technique works only for maximum
degree at most 2 to the
k over 50. um because we restrict how
far
your um your density can go if you want
to apply
this technique like could you ever
expect
that the um the density can go over 2 to
the
k over 50. oh okay so that's a good
question
but i don't think that this was um very
optimized
i mean you know moisture had to stop
somewhere i used to write the paper but
i don't think that there was anything
magic
yeah okay thank you all right thanks
very much leslie this was great i
i i really enjoyed like that we all got
to ask our favorite questions of the
speaker in like full time so
uh hopefully we'll have this for
everyone else yeah we can have some like
silent applause
um and uh yeah
john ming do you want to set up your
slides
hopefully you have the rights to share
your screen if you don't